[Musique]
ça y est un séisme de magnitude 8 6 au
large de la barbade a généré un tsunami
qui devrait toucher nos côtes dans 40
minutes
il faut évacuer tout le littoral y
compris les 240 élèves et le personnel
du collège louis delgrès sa saint pierre
mouais c'est de les combes ou re a collé
d'escalier là là où il ya une fille je
suis là tu vas les points d'eau chaude
pour les stones tout va très vite
grâce aux enseignants et encadrants mais
aussi grâce à une douzaine d'élèves
volontaires chargés de faciliter
l'évacuation du collège jusqu'au stade
situé quelques mètres plus haut
nous avons été en reconnaissant ce mardi
du circuit de l'itinéraire ils ont bien
pris conscience et bilan aujourd'hui
vous voyez que les consignes ont été
strictement piqué et ils ont bien joué
le rôle
on attendait d'eux voilà ça fait partie
de la forme de l'éducation à la
responsabilité
et puis ce sont nos partenaires parce
qu'elle contribue au fonctionnement de
l'établissement
six minutes et 6 secondes pour évacuer
tout le collège le premier bilan est
satisfaisant seul bémol le principal n'a
reçu le sms d'alert qu'après
l'évacuation sans la sirène d'alarmé de
la ville tout le monde serait encore en
danger
à l'intérieur du collège